سترى قبطان قارب صيد
داستن باك يقول إنه لم يرَ المد الأحمر
في خليج تامبا
بهذا السوء ، وآمل أن يكون الأسوأ
وراءنا في خليج تامبا
خائفًا من حدوث ذلك ، لكنني لا
أحبس أنفاسي الطحالب السامة  تحدث الإزهار التي
تسبب نفوق الأسماك ويمكن أن تكون ضارة
للبشر
كل عام تقريبًا في وحول
ساحل فلوريدا
ولكن بالنسبة للصيادين مدى الحياة هذا العام
يختلف
عادةً ما يحدث المد الأحمر في
الخارج
مع التيارات والروابط أو اتجاه الرياح
يمكن أن ينفجر في  ما هو
مختلف عن هذا الشاطئ هو أن هذا بدأ
داخل خليج تامبا
لدينا أسوأ موجة قتل للأسماك
في الربيع
تم إطلاق 215 مليون جالون من مياه الصرف الصحي
في خليج تامبا من مصنع الفوسفات السابق هذا
لتخفيف الضغط على
الخزان المتسرب الذي يمكنك رؤيته للتنظيف
لا يزال جاريًا يقول علماء البيئة
إن الكارثة التي حدثت في
نقطة الصنوبر تغذي المد الأحمر الذي
نراه في خليج تامبا
الآن خمس منظمات  يقاضون
حاكم ولاية فلوريدا القائم بأعمال سكرتير
قسم حماية
البيئة وأصحاب نقاط الصنوبر
يريدون تنظيف المصنع
وإغلاقه بأمان
حتى لا تحدث كوارث بهذا الحجم
مرة أخرى ،
لكن الحاكم رون ديسانتيس يدعي أن
العلم يشير إلى شيء مختلف
الاتجاه
كان الإجماع العلمي واضحًا على أنه
لم يتسبب في المد الأحمر ، كان المد الأحمر
هنا ، حيث قال الحاكم إنه كان إعصار
إلسا في يوليو وليس مياه الصرف الصحي في نقطة الصنوبر
التي أدت إلى قتل الأسماك التاريخي هذا العام
سئل عما إذا كان قد يمارس
السياسة من خلال عدم  لقد كان إعلان حالة
الطوارئ بسبب المد الأحمر في تامبا باي
ديسانتيس متحديًا كيف قمت
بتسييس المد الأحمر ،
فهم من كانوا يقولون إنه يتعين
عليك إعلان حالة
الطوارئ ولذا سألناهم عن سبب
عدم معرفتهم جيدًا  لماذا البيانات
واضحة حقًا
أن تكاثر الطحالب الذي كان يحدث
في خليج تامبا بدأ جيدًا قبل
مرور إعصار إلسا من قبل مايا بيرك
مع الحشوة  يقول برنامج مصب الخليج
إنه بينما ساعدت الأموال التي
أتاحها مكتب الحاكم حتى الآن في
تنظيف الخليج ،
فإنهم بحاجة إلى المزيد منها الآن ، وهي تقول ليس
فقط أن المياه لم تبدو بهذا السوء
منذ السبعينيات
قبل أن يكون هناك قانون للمياه النظيفة
ولكن أيضًا  كان الجدول الزمني للحاكم لمعرفة
سبب المد
الأحمر بعيدًا عن ما فعله إعصار إلسا هو
أنه غير أنماط الرياح ووضع
كل من تعرفهم آلاف الأطنان من
الأسماك الميتة
على طول الواجهة البحرية في وسط المدينة
في سان بطرسبرغ وكان هجومًا
على  تستشعر
المفوضة الزراعية نيكي إطلاق سراح
ديمقراطية أعلنت للتو ترشحها لمنصب
الحاكم ،
ويعتقد أنه بناءً على مستويات السموم العصبية
في المياه ، يمكن أن يكون المد الأحمر ونفوق الأسماك
مشكلة متكررة في الخليج
لأشهر
رأينا حالة الطوارئ التي رأيناها
قادراً على القدوم  هناك في الواجهة الأمامية
للنقطة الصنوبرية ثم
نسيها وانتقل نوعًا ما إلى المشكلة التالية
وبدلاً من الاستمرار في الحصول على
الموارد
ودعمها  جعلك تعلم أنه تم تنظيفه تحت السجادة
مرة أخرى على عبوة المياه ، يقول بعض
الصيادين والمرشدين الذين يعرفهم
أنهم اضطروا إلى المغادرة للعمل في مكان آخر
بينما يتعامل الخليج مع
سمكة غير مسبوقة تقتل
مجموعته الحافظة ، تامبا باي ،
حارس المياه هو أحد المدعين في
الدعوى
نحن نستمر في فعل ذلك كما تعلم أننا نستمر في
قضاء هذا العام في كل
عام ولا أعرف ما إذا كان لدينا
خليج متبقي كما تعلمون أنه سيكون لدينا ماء هنا
لن يرغب أحد في السباحة فيه
ولن يصطاد أحد  فيه